it was quite a chunky manifesto 86 pages
in total almost 16 measures not many are
what you'd call brand-new but certainly
some of them are striking so let's have
a look through a few of them starting
with what comes on page 1 of the
document the label will cut the deficit
every single year of the new Parliament
and in an effort to underscore their
fiscal responsibility they say
everything in the manifesto is costed
which implies cut across the board
except in education health and foreign
aid they promised that they won't raise
taxes like v80 but they will reintroduce
the 50p tax rate for those earning over
150,000 pounds another new promise that
we heard from Miliband today is that he
said he'll extend free childcare for
working parents of three and
four-year-olds from 15 to 25 hours and
he'll double paternity leave 24 weeks
that's going to be paid for in part by
an increase in the bank levy and here's
another promise an extra 2.5 billion
pounds to recruit more staff in the NHS
which labor save will be paid for by a
mansion tax on property is worth over 2
million pounds but they have
subsequently said that they won't match
the conservative pledge of 8 billion
pounds of NHS spending by 2020 but most
of those policies don't carry explicit
costings there's a fast of rising
minimum wage to 8 pounds an hour by 2019
rail fares they're going to be frozen
for a year and there's going to be a new
primary child care service to help with
working families and they're going to
raise some of the money from other tax
changes like cutting the winter fuel
allowance for the top 5% of pensioners
and as we heard last week they're going
to abolish non Dom status though it's
unclear whether that's how you're going
to raise money or cost it Mr Miliband
says the rest of the money is going to
have to come from the non-protected
departments in other words the Home
Office culture and defense and other
parts of government as well though
there's very few numbers on the scale of
those cuts in the document itself on the
labor side the uncertainty is not so
much about where the cuts would come but
actually whether there would be and what
the scale
the cuts or tax rises will be over the
first half of the Parliament because the
fiscal rules they've set themselves are
consistent either with actually nothing
in the way of spending cuts or tax rises
or with over the first two or three
years some really significant tax
increases or spending cuts and we don't
actually know still which path the
Labour Party want to tread finally there
are still some who suspect ed Miliband
has a big policy held back and he might
have some surprises left for the final
weeks of this election campaign